hey 42 here murder call me old-fashioned
but I'm not a fun mailee for moral
reasons but also just so messy
thankfully the law agrees with me
and detectives have become ever more
efficient at tracking down exactly who
is responsible for a particular crime
the various techniques have become
incredibly advanced and now involves
some of the most cutting-edge science so
it's now much harder to convict people
on good old-fashioned reasons such as he
has a shifty face or she just looks like
the type no body part is safe from
forensics these days and it's not just a
dribbling obsessive-compulsive with
dandruff that leaves behind saliva
fingerprints and skin it's all of us so
what are the various techniques that
modern police put to use today we learn
how to catch the killer although the
Chinese use fingerprints in the
seventeen hundreds to identify certain
documents and sculptures it wasn't until
the end of the 19th century that
forensic science really took off the
fingerprint was a star of the show for
many years since Sir William Herschel
started using it in India as a way to
stop forged signatures from the 1860s
onward in 1911 Thomas Jennings was the
first person to be convicted of murder
on the basis of his fingerprints with a
number of experts on hand to give
evidence and fingerprints were placed
Alphonse Bertillon identification method
called anthropometry which was a set of
body measurements found to be far more
reliable as a way to ID people than
using early photographs or just by
asking are you Dave no okay I guess
you've got to go strange though it seems
ballistic fingerprinting actually
started much earlier than real
fingerprinting where an individual
bullet was identified by its shape not
its fingers in case some of you were
confused in 1835 the British police
matched a bullet in a victim to a
bullets making mould in the killer's
house unfortunately we quickly moved
away from Mama's homemade recipe bullets
and mass production prevented this part
of forensics
until Calvin Goddard invented the
comparison microscope in 1925 the first
real tested bullet identification was
after the 1929 Valentine's Day Massacre
when Goddard proved that it wasn't
carried out by rogue cops as suggested
but was in fact Al Capone's henchmen how
romantic
the next big jump was when British
scientist Alec Jeffrey's pioneered DNA
profiling in appropriately the year 1984
big brother isn't just watching you
he's also collecting your skin of course
since the dawn of civilization the most
important part of any crime is the truth
who's telling it who's hiding it and
what was Colonel Mustard doing with it
in the billiard room in China 3,000
years ago
suspects were forced to fill their
mouths with dried rice and after a short
while spit it out again anyone whose
rice was still dry was found guilty of
lying since fear and anxiety were known
to reduce saliva the first lie detection
device that was based on actual science
rather than some sort of magic demon
stick was long brazos glove which
measured blood pressure this eventually
morphed into the polygraph that we know
today you know the machine that everyday
answers the question a millions of TV
viewers lips who was the father
it measures respiratory rate blood
pressure changes and changes in galvanic
skin response which is the bioelectric
reactivity of the skin of course no
polygraph is completely reliable since
the responses that they look for are not
unique to lying they can also be caused
by simply being nervous understanding
the way a killer thinks and behaves has
become a huge part of solving cases and
providing the plots for a never ending
sea of TV detective shows the birth of
forensic psychology probably has its
roots in the notorious Jack the Ripper
mystery when an unknown killer terrified
London with a series of bloody murders
lacking anything concrete
they simply try to build an image of who
their killer was theorizing as to
whether the motivations were madness
sexual religious or a delightful
cocktail
all three what a large proportion of
forensic psychology is not trying to
work out what serial mass murderers eat
for breakfast but more on deciding their
mental health the insanity defense is a
legal classic and goes all the way back
to the Code of Hammurabi in ancient
Mesopotamia the Louvre in Paris houses a
seven and a half foot stone slab
inscribed with much of the law set by
Hammurabi the sixth king of Babylon it
includes mercy for the insane and also
gives us the famous iPhone I some
forensic methods however are a little
more unusual and now I'm not talking
about using a large woman called I'm van
Gogh to talk to the dead and tell us
what Elvis was really up to today JFK
died one thing you don't hear often is
thank goodness for nuclear bomb testing
but using the levels of carbon-14 in
human tissue to get an accurate age
reading has helped a number of cold
cases or thank to the atmospheric nukes
that we detonated during the Cold War
this caused a noticeable global spike in
carbon-14 which is a radioactive form of
carbon that does occur naturally but we
double the levels during these tests
since then it's been declining so you
can actually map the amount and tissue
to approximate dates of global levels
meaning we can detect exactly when
someone died just by their carbon-14
levels sometimes though you don't even
need science you just need good
old-fashioned border gym scarf and Dave
heintzman two detectives in Washington
State designed a set of playing cards to
give out to board prisoners printed with
pictures of cold-case victims their
logic was that the cards would get
around the prison and some prisoners
with a grudge or looking to reduce their
sentence might give up a killer of one
of the victims and it worked in 2011
that get into jail free cards produced a
conviction for the 1979 murder of Susan
Schwarz and what about the future I'm
not talking about a Minority Report
ability to stop murders before they
happen but what tech do we have in the
world
- right now well for why detecting it
would obviously be a great help to
bypass all the obstructive skin and
facial expression nonsense and just get
right into the break a functional MRI
scan is fought to have a 97% accuracy
level for my detection since it shows
the increased blood flow to the brain
that is required to help you create an
untrue story unfortunately it can't be
used on politicians as they are often
shielded from the raised by their
unwieldly comb-overs rumor has it that
one particular politician has developed
an impenetrable golden massive hair that
enables him to lie with impunity and as
for DNA well gentlemen I have some bad
news for us it's now possible to have a
good guess at a man's surname just by
looking at his Y chromosome the male
chromosome has been passed down fairly
unchanged from generation to generation
so by building a database of old samples
with names that we know the police can
look for a similar Y chromosome to yours
and it's almost a one in four chance
that they can guess your surname so I
hope this has been useful if you're
thinking about rounding up a crime
solving team and since I'm an Equal
Opportunities youtuber if you are
planning a murder and this video has
helped you you are very welcome but
seriously kids don't try this at home
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 but there's a map equally as
despicable as Adolf Hitler yet very few
people even know of his existence you
may be either grossed out when I tell
you this or totally amazed
but inside the chrysalis the caterpillar
completely liquid Isis